red box habe ich bereits hier ist ein
magier aloha und seien herzlich
willkommen zu einem weiteren zeit des
megaprojekts und wir sind immer noch in
dem fantastischen gespannt mit kompakter
zusammen wo es gibt so ich werde mich
weiter an meinem bett box setzen
ok alles also mir ist aufgefallen dass
die lava die ich in meinem haus gestellt
habe marmor zum brennen bringt es
hingeht einfach mal ins fach sein
end portal oder netter vorteil zu mir
ein netter reck
ich finde so krank in den text so bett
box habe ich bleibe hier ist ein
argument
ja es heißt will ist das bild das hat
mich auch schon getötet das töten
dagegen schlagen mit dem schwert oder
was weiß ich dass mich getötet
ganz kurze frage muss sich beck box
direkt neben links stellen
red box hat verschiedene ausgänge es
heißt es hat einen input und alle
anderen seiten sind sonst output dahin
wo die du wenn du stellst das was dir
entgegenkommt ist der einzige input das
heißt das muss quasi hinter general sei
nicht wo es platziert aber ganz normal
du kannst mit einem rechtsklick das
heißt dass die noch mal das french
kannst das umdrehen wie du willst
hab ich glaube ich hab schon richtig
gestellt power level 0 das heißt muss
ich muss den generator antreiben ich
weiß nicht wie nimm dir das war ja wie
mache ich denn solar erfüllen sie in
peace ja das gebe ich dann ein solar
oder was
das war es schon ja ich gebe ich kämpfe
jetzt einfach mit dem jetpack gegen den
gast ich schau mal wie es ist
die solar im handel das alles möglich
mit solar wie machen das ja solar panel
das ist ja dieser kasten der erste
wettkampf baby guten erfolg bekommen und
wertsachen gejobbt und zwar
schwarzpulver und eine gastprofessur
just sollte aufpassen dass hier wirklich
nicht im zu weit weg fliege ich glaube
ich finde den eingang nicht mehr wo ich
den hydra chip chorherr trade co ich
brauche dafür hüther rad einfach an
kohle in 036 oder mails rater ach du
scheiße wo ein fahrfehler aus okay leute
ich probiere jetzt mal ein bisschen rum
aber das wollte er dass ich mich da so
ein bisschen rand hast also ich hoffe
ihr seid ihr zufrieden
ach du scheiße habe mich verlaufen
solche never kommen damit ihr den weg
weisen kann ja bitte
hier ist eine firma aus dies aus feuer
die vor cosmi stirn habe ich jetzt
getötet und hat ein paar kohl das sehr
schön ja das werden dann geht das
natürlich schnell wo bist du denn es
soll ja warte ich komme jetzt aber ich
bin auf dem weg aber es ist damals mit
bussen ein portal das ist wie viel
energie ich noch hab mich dass ich hier
kann man marwijk
verstehe ich gar nichts mehr ich habe
keine ahnung wo ich bin
muss mir unbewegten weg in der rada wo
bist du du bist auch bisher den weg in
den berg hoch gekraxelt da oben ist der
eingang 30 bis 50 von mir weg als habe
ich den penis perfekt nächsten 30 bist
du von mir weg dann kilian ding jetzt
einen wegpunkt meisters wegpunkte neuer
wegpunkt aktiv weiß man einfach auf m
oder fertig bearbeiten ist doch einfach
auf m oder ach so ja genau und man kann
da einstellen ob das welche farbe und
auch das nur netter ist ich glaub schon
dass es irgendwie ging ich war bei dir
und habe eben einen rabatt dingsbums
abholen was davon reingelegt hat das
heißt die never punkt sehe ich jetzt ne
das pony ich hier rein
ich hoffe ich sehe ja normalen welt
nicht aber ich sehe auch in anderen
punkt deswegen vermute ich mal das ich
das pons richter aufläuft
das heißt weg punkten aus so was hat
meine bienchen gemacht weil die
prinzessin und weil die bedrohen das ist
fantastisch hier eine prinzessin und
eine waldbühne okay das ungut
ich habe eine kultivierte drohne
bekommen das ist schon die nächste
erweiterung aber ich will erst mal ein
bisschen baldig machen also weil dich
und kultiviert ich hoffe da kommt was
geiles los hier waldkönigin gemeinde
drohne
die meinl ohne mit zwei dicke bohne das
viertägige ich nehme mich da in die gene
in die gerne mit baldige als schöne
königin nähen kann ich nicht da wo ich
bin gespannt ich bin gespannt
also die kann ich nicht verwenden
königin ist ärgerlich gleich habe ich
keine prinzessin ist das noch gut warum
bringen der prinzessin in berlin vor
allem ich brauche generator und auf
jeden fall lag phoenix zeigt auf jeden
fall dass man muss broich muss man noch
ein generator machen ziemlich ist
defizit gerade hier
ich habe gleich keine prinzessin mehr
das ist eigentlich bitter das ist also
eine habe ich jetzt noch ein überschuss
von iris menn
die waadtländer man ja noch eine
prinzessin ok alles klar honig honig
nicht in die truhe tun kann
ich war mir glaube ich noch ein paar von
diesen boxen hier damit noch mehr bienen
züchten kann
gleichzeitig haben wir daher wenn du
willst kann man schlafen gehen brauche
ich gar nicht allerdings also mir ist es
egal wer dann das mitte schlafengehen
noch
ich glaube jetzt ja gute nacht und
bricht liegt ja da fantastisch war
nämlich ein weiteres gehäuse
ach so aber es endlich auch gar nicht
angeschmissen kostet natürlich alles
energie dann können wir schauen wir
haben jetzt hier das nicht klappt
könnten wir jetzt irgendwas us-cent
nehmen wir etwa die dass ich mit vier
redstone von den clown muss farmen mein
lieber gebe ich darauf zurück nur ich
möchte es nicht extra für den vier
redstone farben gehen
ich gehe gleich eva dann gehe ich
erstmal 04 redstone und dann ist es
später dann später so schneider dass wir
das allerletzte sein das ist als
erstmals letzte was ich brauche für das
jahr so hier ist noch feuer und zauber
das tor nicht
schade dass ich den honig nicht nutzt
kann ein produziere ich ja selbst
vielleicht die bücher oder blättern wie
so was genau zusammen imprägniertes
gehäuse wieder fertig gestellt das heißt
wir können ganz simpel jetzt auch noch
zack zack zack
dann haben wir nämlich unser fünftes
bienen häusl 1
ich mache zwei abstand sollte passen die
königin wenn wir die hier und eine
baldige sobald wald ich kann arbeiten
perfekt arbeitet arbeitet und arbeitet
sehr gewaltige könig haben können wir
uns kultivierte könige machen also da
brauch man ein paar generationen für die
arbeitet auch fantastisch so dann fahren
wir weiter
ich weiß noch nicht wie das ganze
funktioniert mit den bienen was du da
die ganze zeit fabriziert ja also
eigentlich es bringt auch wirklich nicht
nur wachsen kann daraus kann nicht mehr
gummi oder so dass man weiß eigentlich
ist es wirklich sehr sehr sense lässt
aber na ja weil ich kann ja inhalt des
deutschen immer im gang seien
so ich hab ich werde mir jetzt angewöhnt
nebenbei einfach meine meine meinung zu
checken
also ich würd auch nachschauen ich habe
jetzt hier so viel honig ich kann hier
nichts machen
also ich kann hier nur carpenter ich
kann hier verpackte honig farbe und was
soll mir das bringt mir nichts
also ist nicht doch nicht ich kann da
nur wasserleitungen machen offenbar sich
die kabinen wachs und honig tropfen raus
wieder zwei witze brauche ich jetzt
einfach farbe meine fresse und tropfen
bringt mir beschleuniger was das denn
egal ist denn eigentlich schleuniger
egal ich jetzt haben dann bricht der
ganze sache mit
sie haben ihr feuer ich komme mal diesen
stein rein super mal nein das ist auch
nicht der fall
vielleicht ein bisschen schnell der fall
hieß vielleicht glas dass bei derart
einer gestorben
denn meine wieder zocken und die fehlen
auch mal so durch wie ich die ganze
familie sei aber geil achtet brüder
zocken sind eigene wohnung oder oder mit
denen von einer wg also wurde ich mir zu
hause aber mit einem gast sein wie zu
hause hat durchgängig sturmfrei fakten
ist gehören vielleicht nein nein nein
ist es auch nicht
glas auch nicht also viel kann es nicht
mehr sein knochenmehl ist es auch nicht
mehr
vielleicht die torchance doch wünschen
oder ich meine sie mal wieder neues
rezept ist das nicht vielleicht das
steak wieder ein abstieg
laut stehe ich ist es nicht weil das
stativ eine freude ist weil es ist auch
nicht wollte
heute ist es auch nicht man ist ja
wirklich nur am rumprobieren dass es
etwas mehr
das ist auch nicht aber eins gehört noch
dazu wo sich nehmen soll
laut paschen und das hier vielleicht
noch ein skelett runter also irgendwie
wird das ganze hier nichts
ich wusste es doch dass es lux ist etwa
so und jetzt mal was dritt wissen wochen
tortoise und ich habe glaube ich das
ganze zeit genauer strom gemacht das
heißt so ist es herausfinden
ich weiß ich weiß nicht wo ist jeder
unterschied denken und kurios ich habe
keine ahnung
tv action leute was nun umgesetzt
frage ist was brauchen wir jetzt ich
wette raum wieder magic das lässt mir
den arsch auf grundeis gehen
magic ist jeden moment kaputt explosion
mit dem das haben wir noch nicht gehabt
wir hatten ein feuerstein schon werten
im prime knowledge fragment ich muss ja
auch verschiedene sachen dann kräften
wahrscheinlich noch extra dafür damit
ich ein pilz zum beispiel der giftig ist
sie spinnen auge
das da rein lopez ist auch nicht ich
lasse ich einfach mal fahren derzeit bei
flexit auch nicht also keine begegnung
beim packen amboss
mein rucksack bestimmt rein achso metall
aber noch ganz vergessen
ich tue mir einfach ein bisschen mit
teil ein geländer bild das wir haben
gold nugget hier haben lapislazuli wir
haben wirklich alles hier da die frage
ist was ich nehme was man am meisten und
silber beim absolut nicht dass wir
silber hier ein wirklich nur um
probieren oder als ob wirklich wenn
man's dann hat man aber erst einmal hat
dann hat man das rezept halten aber das
ist ein dass apathie das bringt doch gar
nix oder ich hab also hier ist wertvoll
dabei dass sie die ganze zeit ab und die
sind unendlich viele ärzte davon leicht